the bantay kickboxing World Championship
is up for grabs the winner becomes a two
sport world champion winning this belt
is going to be a dream come true for me
Jonathan hag 100% my greatest
achievement is going to try to do the
unthinkable you're going to see a
different monster in front of them it's
Champion versus
champion
through the city like I'm onion get it
the
city and now
Brandon
six what is popping fam it is Monday
morning October 30th on this chilly
chilly brisk Monday morning here in
Calabasas California I'll tell you what
it's it's these weekends it's weekends
like these that make you happy to be
part of this MMA Journey that we're all
on I couldn't wait to jump on this mic
and just just rant about Francis and
Gano now if you're watching this live
you guys just saw the little trailer
little Sizzle reel for you for one
Championship it is going down Friday one
of my faves in all of Combat Sports
Jonathan Hagerty is putting his freak
skills to the test against fabriccio
Andra Brazil's finest for the
bantamweight kickboxing World
Championship hagard if you don't know
this dude you should he is an absolute
Savage from the UK he's one of my
favorite fighters of all time um I'm
biased man my mom's English I think he's
gonna absolutely destroy Andra but um
Andra is a straightup killer you guys
would know him uh if especially if
you're UFC base uh he his last fight he
beat John liner who's uh was an absolute
monster in the UFC he's been a Savage
across the pond when I say across the
pond I mean in Asia for one Championship
the dynamic explosive hitter John L
liner got stopped in the fourth round by
Andra in his last MMA fight but now he's
jumping and he's the bantamweight
champion over there in one Championship
but now he's coming over to kickboxing
he has a background in kickboxing as
well but not like my boy John John I
call him John John his friends call him
John John
[Music]
hag that's going down this freaking
Friday an Amazon Prime one Championship
just just spitting out hot content for
you guys in the fight world and then one
of the uh GH he's up there man one of
the Ruto Brothers is uh is competing
again Nobody Does it bigger in the in
the grappling uh sphere than one
Championship you're talking about world
title grappling competition it's Ruto
vers magamed and that's for the
welterweight submission grappin world
championship and that's one of a kind
first to do it Ruto is
gonna strangle mamed that's what's going
to happen maged extensive background
ADCC never won it but has competed a few
times I think he was a Russian trials
ADCC champ but that's not the big dog
and Ruto um it's just these young kids
man he's these young kids when we
started Jiu-Jitsu it was always you know
the older people or you have any really
young kids who started in the Jiu-Jitsu
that it is now and Ruto has shown you
that uh these kids can do it all man
he's an absolute Savant when it comes to
Jiu-Jitsu one of the best in the world
so make sure you tune in this Friday on
Amazon Prime it's one Championship one
of the best if not the best promotion
all the land and that is going down uh
November 3rd that's Friday at 8:00 p.m.
Eastern now I will be watching that in
my green room because I will be in
Niagara Falls never been probably jump
down the waterfall we'll see how it goes
I'm in niagar Falls this Friday and
Saturday one show Friday one show
Saturday at senica casino out there
nigar Falls heard it's 20 minutes from
Buffalo probably not especially in the
weather we'll see hopefully there's no
snow up there um but yeah those shows
almost sold out so get your tickets the
few that are left that's a Casino
Niagara Falls and then just announced
for the keep on truck in 2023 24 Tour
really uh Chicago is December 8th and
9th two shows Friday two shows Saturday
and then I uh keep on trucking dude
that's the name of the tour Nashville's
January 25th one night only that's
January 25th that's a Thursday because
I'm jumping on a plane Friday and
Saturday January 26 27th I'm in Austin
Texas baby so come get you some keep on
trucking tour enough of this enough of
all this because it is October 30th the
day before Halloween and um we got to
talk Tyson Fury Francis and
ganu um where do we
start this is a lot to get into and I'm
sure I'm going to rant and be all over
the place so hang tight kids drink your
dark roast coffee and let's go for a
ride for this Francis andano tyon Fury
fight so
um just just to break down kind of the
whole promotional thing of it being in
Saudi Arabia um you know one of the
problems with box and it's been
historically documented is they haven't
been able to keep up with the production
value of a the UFC UFC does it best Bara
not even close uh and boxing has just
never found their kind of niche in that
highlevel production this was no
different um even though all the Saudi
money in the world couldn't get this
thing to kind of go smoothly there was
hiccups there's green screen the
commentators had to fill hours and hours
I started this pay-per-view at 11:00
a.m. here Pacific and it didn't get done
to about 430 that's five and a half
hours the last UFC pay-per-view major
pay-per-view took an hour and 20
minutes I don't want to do anything for
five hours and I love the fist s cuffs I
don't do anything for five hours that
thing shouldn't have been five hours um
I'm not there to see Becky G and when
they keep playing the Francis this and
Tyson's this and here's their background
this is their story This Is How They
started I already paid
$79.99 I'm already sold who are you
telling this story to we've already
bought the G goddamn fight quit selling
this story over and over for five hours
of just complete
it was painful man it was
painful and I get it they're like uh you
know Saudi Arabia wants to be the
One-Stop shop where you know they make
it a an event it's just more than a
fight for them it's an event and they
had the the Chic or the king whatever
you call it no disrespect of Saudi
Arabia there every time they said his
name they cheered I don't know if that's
a thing where if like they don't cheer
they get shot in the face you know it's
very strange I don't know delay of the
land over there when Brian's in studio
I'm sure he can break it down and put us
to sleep with it which will do um so I
don't know the lay of the land there but
what they were going for they
accomplished now the only reason I don't
care about any of that stuff is because
the the actual fight was fantastic the
you had an actual competitive fight if
that fights a snoozefest or uh Tyson V
have to carry Francis and you're like
what is going on here then all that
spectacle they're screwed this whole
Saudi Arabia investment that they're
making into the sports world is screwed
but you forget about all that because
the actual product which is why we're
tuning in was fantastic which this is a
huge huge drastic difference between
Tyson Fury and Francis ganu and say Jake
Paul insert whatever fighter uh Logan
Paul insert Dylan danis uh KSI Tommy
Fury the reason why you feel weird when
you watch that or pay for that is cuz
the actual product and we know it and
you know going into it it even though
the buildup sells us on a different
story those fights for real fight fans
suck let's be honest those fights suck
they're not very entertaining the
buildup is what we're paying for and you
because you know why oh because they're
not
professionals they're not they're just
not but again I'm not hating on that
this was completely different this is
the first time we've ever seen something
like this now you guys are going to say
Conor McGregor Floyd Mayweather now
there there is no Tyson Fury versus
Francis if there was no Conor vers Floyd
Connor set the the path so all this
could happen but Connor versus Floyd was
never a competitive fight Floyd carried
him in that fight we all knew it and we
knew he didn't have a shot nobody was
going to get knocked out um we all knew
what was going on there and it was the
elep in the room with Francis Tyson
because we've watched all these
influencer YouTuber fights the Tommy
Fury fights the Jake Paul fights
um you know even Mike Tyson Holyfield
all that or Roy Jones whoever the hell
it was all that stuff is in a completely
different Lane than Tyson Fury and
Francis and ganu and the problem is is
the lines are getting blurred and
they're not they're very separate and he
saw that uh on Saturday
afternoon and I I think even part of my
bias was taking things from those other
kind of influence or fights and putting
my own bias on this fight I don't think
anyone could have predicted what Frances
did and I also don't think the majority
of casual consumers realize what Francis
pulled off on Saturday
afternoon um even when I was walking in
this this guy who works upstairs you
know
who C very casual consumer of the fight
game but he likes it and he'll me and
him a talk when we run run into each
other before he goes up to sell whatever
he's doing upstairs he goes dude didn't
see the fight but I heard not that
thing's rigged right that's not real I
went excuse me he goes That's not come
on that's not real I went what do you
mean it's not real he goes come on
Francis the MMA guy went to a split
decision with Tyson Fury the best to do
it I went oh hold on you think Tyson
Fury agreed to look bad and lose stock
the the value of his stock in the boxing
world for what he's getting paid the
same regardless you think he went oh
yeah that makes sense I want to be like
have a good day have a good day but
because we're so used to this influencer
boxing world and some of it looks
suspect which it's not but that's easy
to that's the the the knock on them
again you're letting that bias of all
that come over to Francis and
Tyson which was a legit fight so when
you get into the
fight I think too a lot of us didn't
realize how good Francis was at boxing
we've never seen him boxing before so I
said my prediction or my advice to
Francis which most of you agreed on was
don't try to box him throw CAU in the
wind he he he hasn't seen somebody with
your power hope he can connect with him
get this thing
done
that's based off all the knowledge we
had of Francis going into this fight his
Rosen streo fight you got to remember
too in
hindsight Francis isn't known as the
most technical striker in the UFC of all
time by by any facet so we had no
background to base no he's going to look
like an actual boxer going against the
greatest heavyweight of all time nobody
called that that'd be very challenging
to do and you just be be pulling out of
your ass the other problem you have too
and I tell Brian this all the freaking
time and his old ass doesn't listen you
can't watch guys hit mits and then go oh
man his techniques off oh he doesn't
look good mits don't count mits have
never counted anybody you can be more of
a casual if you watch somebody on
Instagram or Tik Tok wherever you're get
consuming your uh fighter coverage if
you're watching a clip on there going oh
it just doesn't look great oh his hands
are down he's hitting Ms or he's hitting
the B that stuff never put any value
into any of that ever ever ever ever so
when you look at the
fight um the other thing you're going to
hear going around social media or going
around your local freaking casual
upstairs is Francis looked terrible man
he didn't even train for this thing oh
really how do you know that oh he just
didn't look good right well according to
to Tyson Fury sorry I said Francis
according to Tyson you're going to say
Tyson didn't trained for this Tyson
looked bad that's the reason why Francis
had success okay what gives you that
conclusion or where you find that he
just didn't look himself cool you don't
know what you're talking about
according to Tyson Fury he trained 12
weeks for
this that's coming out of his mouth his
exact words were oh I'm I'm taking him
as serious as I can I train 12 weeks
just like anybody he's a big strong
powerful dude I'm not overlooking any
body and even before this every Joe
Schmo that had a freaking mic went up to
him goes I know that you're doing this
and you know Tyson's a big powerful guy
but usk but usk everyone usk usyk in
December usyk in December this is a
tuneup fight to get ready for usk and
what Fury say I'm not looking past
anybody man I've did 12 weeks of Camp
those are the words coming out of his
mouth I did 12 weeks of Camp to prepare
for TI for Francis and G
those were his exact words so I'm going
to believe him on that now did he look
like the same fighter that fought Wilder
no did he look like the same guy that
fought and beat Klitschko no he didn't
I'll give you that but according to his
entire camp and anybody that knows Tyson
better than any blogger vlogger tick
tocker influencer is Tyson fur in his
Camp they said we prepared 12 weeks for
the best version of Francis zanu here's
the problem with that they didn't
realize how damn good Francis andano was
at boxing they had no clue neither did
you neither did I neither did nobody
anybody in this room Francis and
ganu looked fantastic from every aspect
from every aspect I had him win that
fight I watched it again this morning
you could easily give him four to five
rounds plus you give him the 108 round
for the knockdown and he he he landed
more significant strikes did Tyson do
his boxing thing land some jobs Jabs and
stay active towards the later rounds yep
but overall France has won that
fight and I I I tweet this out you're
bat crazy if you think the boxing
world who hates MMA who hates anything
about MMA you're bat crazy if you think
those old school dinosaur judges in any
facet unless it was a complete lights
out knockout we're going to give Francis
ganu that fight via decision there's not
a chance remember what goes into this in
December it's not going to happen in
December but planned as of now
tentatively in December December 25th
France or Tyson is supposed to fight
usyk in that same Arena probably with
the same judges with the same backing
from the Saudis do you really think that
they would give a MMA guy with zero
boxing experience a decision win over
Tyson Fury
the greatest heavyweight of all time the
I think he's number four on the
pound-for-pound rankings the lineage
Champion do you think they would give a
MMA guy with zero boxing experience a
freaking chance to win via decision not
a CH there's not a more corrupt sport on
this planet than
boxing as soon what decision went
there's not a chance they give to
Francis not a chance it's to them the
rules it's boxing them are the cheating
rules it's just what they do that's why
their sport is in shambles it just is
it's always been the you know this weird
finicky kind of dark world where there's
promoters and the mafia be involved
probably still are you got the Saudi
money they put all this investment in
Tyson Fury fighting usyk you think
they're going to allow a curveball and
have Francis win via decision not a
chance did France win that fight yes
yeah he did yeah he did he he did man
and he looked
fantastic he was going traditional he
was going Southpaw and also remember
going into this all these old boxing
dinosaurs who can't just give it up went
I bet I bet France is going to do
something Shady in the clinch I bet he's
going to go for a guillotine I bet he's
going to throw an
elbow who threw the
elbow who got weird in the clinch
Francis was disengaging go no no get
back get the hell back and was not dirty
in any fat look at this elbow
yeah it did land too hell yeah it
land and you can't tell me fury won that
fight looking at his face post fight
look at his face Francis doesn't have a
scratch on him now here's what's
interesting this is the most interesting
thing to
me oh weird you think Canelo Alvarez
knows a thing or two about boxing he
thought Francis won
LeBron I don't care uh I mean might as
well be Oprah but uh sudo he knows the
stuff yeah the UFC a little bias am my a
little bias for sure take your bias out
of it rewatch that
fight tell me one I know it's so tough
for these old heads to give it up man
it's like me with electric cars not
never are some faster sure I don't care
I'll freaking rag on them all day to the
day I'm in the grave man I hate them do
they do some things better than uh
combustion cars sure I hate them we'll
never give it up never 10 eight rounds
for combustion all day long what's this
I'm just looking at the
faces there's Tyson you can see he's
those are bad I'm sure you can find
better ones on Instagram just looking
right now yeah those are tough but for
for Tyson now let me ask you guys this
who's interested there he is who's
interested in Tyson versus usk
now there is no hype on that fight it
was the only fight I wanted to see I
want to see Tyson vers
Francis that's the
fight I want to see Francis vers Wilder
I want to see Francis versus freaking
Anthony Joshua Francis hey kids is a
boxer now hey
pfl take a hike I know you guys own his
MMA rights or whatever you have to allow
him to do this be cool man be cool you
got to be cool Francis is a boxer now he
can
make ungodly money just boxing
pfl Who you gonna give him
now who are you GNA give him where he's
going to make $30 million in
MMA go ahead name a single fighter you
can pull from any roster where he can
make the same money get the same
attraction as he could in a Tyson Fury
rematch a Wilder fight an Anthony Joshua
fight he is a boxer now he's a boxer
that's what he is he's 36 years old we
don't have time to play grab ass in the
pfl he a boxer pfl be cool don't be like
Dana White don't let your ego get
involved with this he's a Saudi Arabian
boxer now and he's going to make all the
cash in the world and for Joshua going
oh this is a circus is it I got news for
you pal he did better against Tyson than
you would
have come get some and all of them are
foaming at the boxing deck to line up
and get their shot at Francis zanu he's
the ball of the dance isn't it
great all the odds are against him
dude all the odds are against him it's
the greatest accomp lishment in Combat
Sports history maybe top five in all of
sports if you don't realize this you
don't know about fighting or Sports
what he achieved what he accomplished is
nuts but he lost VI a split decision but
he didn't we all know he won we know he
won just getting the knockdown I was
like as soon as he got the knockdown oh
we we're going sizler Daddy I don't care
what happens rest fight even then after
the knockdown everybody in their
freaking gay ants text me oh my God cool
yeah yeah I went yeah but Tyson is gonna
pick it up now and and Francis breathing
a little hard I I bet he gets finished
in the eighth or ninth round maybe TKO
in the 10th because Tyson realize he's
in a fight now it was good and it got
him he did his job and that's going be
an epic picture but it's going to get a
little dicey from
now
nope nope he was in a fight and what
Tyson Fury say he gave me the toughest
fight in the last 10 years hey boxers
where you at dude you guys gave MMA all
this I get it I get it we can even
beat a Jake Paul you know Connor could
beat Floyd I get it but what's up now
what's up now and it open now it opens
up the floodgates for MMA boxing
crossover now sugar shano Mali versus
dvon Davis doesn't sound so funny does
it be careful with that here's the
difference and I'm not here to rain on
the parade I'm all about these crazy
fights you guys know this content for
days I love it this stuff I get my rocks
off too especially when a guy upsets
another you know great I love it you got
to realize
though even though Tyson Fury is so
skilled anony Joshua so skilled Deontay
Wilder so skilled Francis ganu very
skilled remember they're heavyweights
they're heavyweights so they the least
skilled out of all the weight divisions
they get by with a lot of power they get
by with other things that the lighter
weights can't it it's in just Combat
Sports period whether it's one
Championship whether it's UFC pfl and
then over to boxing the heavyweights
aren't as skilled technically as the
lighter
weights so at heavyweight you're going
to get a much
more closer fight I'll say that you
you'll get a closer fight because the
skill set isn't as wide as say a javante
Davis sugar
Shan when when when you when you start
crossing over and these guys are calling
out you know the the lighter weight
classes then boxing you should be happy
because if the lighter weights decide to
jump in that pool and you do get insert
tank Davis sugar Shan that's a little
different but with Francis and at
heavyweight they can make up the
difference they can make it a
competitive fight if you're at the level
of T Francis so I caveat with that you
got you France a very very high level
and can we just I know I'm all over the
place but Nick
sick I mean if I'm an MMA guy I am
buying a oneway ticket to Las Vegas what
is he the greatest coach of all time
came up with a game plan for Strickland
be Izzy Izzy greatest midweight of all
time came up with the game plan for
Francis to beat Tyson Fury greatest box
of all time hey MMA young heads get a
one way ticket to Vegas if we'll have
you I don't know what the conditions are
over there he's probably pretty busy I
would get a oneway ticket and freaking
nicksick and I would freaking live at
his feet that's what I would do that's
what I would
do it's an insane story man it's the the
movie is gonna be sick Francis and Gano
movie is gonna be absolutely insane
absolutely insane
insane I can't believe what he's able to
pull off and and here here's what bums
me out about all
this as much as we don't want to say
it's UFC versus boxing this was even
more UFC vers boxing than Conor vers
Floyd because we actually had a chance
here and it it pains me to see that Dana
White's not part of it because you have
Izzy there you had Usman there you had
Conor McGregor there you had Vince
McMahon there you had the Undertaker
there which are under the TK o right and
Dana White's ego he can't give it up and
it's very very rare where Dana White
makes a mistake of this magnitude he
made a royal mistake Ben against Francis
nanu to be fair as a businessman he
probably made the right choice in
hindsight now that we're here royal
royal mess up because you have the most
relevant fighter on the planet and he's
not with the
UFC he has nothing to do with the UFC
matter of fact he hates the
UFC and it was you had all these UFC
representatives there you had the the
legends of the sport with Izzy Usman
Connor you had all these guys there and
Dana White's nowhere to be found when
they asked Dana HPR just go kid did good
that's it that's all you're gonna get
out of them and they have the most
relevant figh on the planet whether it's
boxing kickboxing jiujitsu wrestling the
most relevant figh on the planet is name
is Francis zanu and he has nothing to do
with the UFC matter of fact he despises
the
UFC and Dan has it is no part of it when
if you could have just played ball where
could have just been cool for once in
your life you could have been part of
this historic moment name the last time
you had this it's never happened before
name the last time you had this big of a
historic moment in the UFC is not
associated with
it then happen no some of the some of
the influencer boxing but that's
different we're talking historical
Sports here this was a historical sports
moment and Dana's ego got in the way
doesn't allow him to play ball he can't
be in the Cool Kids Club fifth week man
was there TKO
representative all the other guys are
there Dana is nowhere to be found it's
such a shame it's it it bums me out it
bums me out but usually Dana's Dana's
usually right Dana's usually right here
he he missed it major Miss biggest
mistake at Dana White's
career biggest mistake at Dana White's
career because now Fran and ganu you
gotta realize no matter what happens
now everybody wants a shot at him Wilder
Joshua and Tyson has to rematch him
again they didn't have a rematch Claus
in the contract which I I'm all about it
doesn't matter even if you got to lose
to usyk even if he beats usyk the
Francis ganu fight hanging over his head
he looked bad most of the MMA world and
a lot of the boxing World thought he
lost that fight he has to redeem himself
that fight is there now and it's even
bigger than the first one now and then
you have Joshua there you have Wilder
there all of those fights are on the
table for Francis and
ganu so many people gave Francis Flack
so many people when he left the
UFC including me as far as MMA goes I
did not think pfl was the answer I don't
know how they're going know come up with
the funds and come up with the opponents
to make him relevant I I I still agree
with that but what I said is if you go
back and listen I said the only way that
this works out for Francis for leaving
the UFC it's not going to be the pfl
it's not the one Championship the only
it works out if he lands a Tyson Fury
fight here we are he lands Tyson Fury
fight MMA is in the rear viiew miror for
Francis ganu it doesn't matter not pfl
not UFC not one Championship it's all
about boxing Francis is a boxer now
Francis can make all the money in the
world boxing the biggest names in the
world and they're all down now
everyone's down before it was a circus
now they see a skill set they're all on
board France can make a100 million I bet
you by the by the time this all said and
done 30 30 30 damn and then with
sponsors the movie The Book he's the
most relevant fighter on the
planet it's insane and you this is
what's crazy you you know when Francis
knocked him down and he was like saying
something and I was going no Francis
don't do that CU he's usually so humbled
I went no no don't do that when they
went beginning of the fight when we went
to touch gloves Tyson goes I'm GNA take
you to school when he knocked him down
he said you're a terrible
Professor what and danced too and danced
his big ass was dancing it was like the
robot from uh Mean Girls oh not mean
girls white chicks remember the White
Chicks guy that's what he was like like
man um it was just historic now remember
all the Flack Francis got there's one
guy we got to give it up to and his
name's uh Marquel shout out to marel
Martin yeah Marquel Martin had this
vision and he got dragged through the
freaking fire like you wouldn't believe
I'm sure at times even Francis doubted
the idea and the the vision and marel
stuck to it he took so much heat for it
he banked on his guy and he and he won
he put all his chips in francis's corner
not a bad guy to put your chips on
knowing his background not a bad guy to
bank on E that being said I I I wouldn't
have Bet On It Just historically it
doesn't you any time somebody goes
against UFC they lose Francis destroyed
them in this he was one he's won so
shout out to Markel man you freaking
boys did it dude which is nuts I don't
think anybody listen I love Francis
andana I didn't Envision this I thought
it was going to get starched I thought
he was going to get absolutely
smoked no no no no no no he looked like
a straight up
boxer a professional and he has zero
experience in boxing zero kids no
amateur no Golden Gloves no smokers No
One op nothing went against the number
one pound-for-pound heavyweight in the
world and beat him via boxing there's
only one guy cheating in there throwing
elbows doing dirty stuff in the clinch
and it wasn't the MMA fighter it was the
actual boxer he's one dude tell you who
else won Saudi
Arabia all those four and a half hours
that you wasted my life I'll never get
back it was long dude it was so bad
those four and a half hours all good
dude all good they won that Prince of
Saudi Arabia a prince King I don't know
the rules I'm not trying to be
disrespectful I don't I I don't know the
lay of land there that Prince King that
they cheered for every time otherwise I
think they get put down but that Prince
and King that they cheered for boy they
made an event now I can't wait to see
the next
one people going oh does it make you
want to go to it no no don't be insane
no I'm not flying out to Saudi AR
whatever dude not never whatever now if
I was working it I would but just to go
no I would work it 100% I could use the
gig they would pay you so much money
just to be there like I'm in dude I'm in
100% I'm not saying that I'm saying like
as a spectator just to buy ticket for
the ne I mean it's history so I get it
but what the point is there Saudi Arabia
made this massive investment did they
get their money back probably not the
amount of money that they spent we got
to see the pay-per-views I'm curious on
the pay-per-views because Francis nor
Tyson have have ever been a major
pay-per-view draw in the grand scheme of
things but I I think the next one will
be
huge the the best is they had usyk uh
ringside and he was just like what in
the the hell he was so nervous nobody's
talking about that fight now
nobody and as as awkward as Francis was
as awkward as Francis was you know who's
more awkward and very skilled a guy
named
usk it's a tough fight for for Tyson
also you got realize Tyson's a tader I
think he's 35 France is actually older
than he is France you know so Tyson's a
little older I don't know how much more
has in the tank he's been doing a hot
second if he lose to usyk I don't think
it you know um does anything with the
rematch if he beats usk I think it makes
Francis look better and then that
rematch would be even even bigger here's
the caveat though that Francis and usyk
I'm sorry that Tyson and usyk fight
there there's a rematch clause in that
so is Francis going to wait a year and a
half two years to fight Fury in the
rematch probably not I bet he's gonna
get a Joshua a Wilder in between
then if again if pfl plays Ball but bfl
come on right hey bfl come on get out of
here right kick rocks or just be cool
just be part of it but don't don't hurt
Francis and don't hurt the fan base by
allowing him to give us these boxing
fights because I know you paid for MMA
guy you got boxer now he boxer he's a
biggest boxer in the world now and it's
fantastic so this is according to report
by Sports payout the fight 1.5 million
who knows yeah it's always like who
knows true or not yeah it's always high
so but by the way Francis is 37 and um
Tyson's 35 yep their ages yep yeah so
Fran you know Francis has three years to
get this but you turn 40 I mean there's
the George Foreman the world there
Bernard Hopkins I get all that he's not
them he has two three years Max one
fight a year 30 million Joshua Wilder
Fury no MMA pfl cannot offer he has all
the power there's no MMA fight they can
make now maybe Jon
Jones that would be great because how
dope was it that you're watching this on
ESPN
plus and you were getting actual Francis
Gano UFC highlights the actual real
footage not the weird stuff they have to
do yeah because Mickey Mouse owns all of
it any he went we're down we don't know
the whole drama The Real Housewives of
UFC we don't give a crap yeah let him
use the
footage Dana must have hated that these
are the same guys that blurred out the
logo on usman's shirt during the
embedded that's how Petty they
are and for the fir I can't remember
last time a guy's won like
this I'm not anti- Dana I'm not I it's
just he it's very rare you see him make
a mistake of this magnitude again in
hindsight he made the right choice
Francis asking for too much especially
for the company it's going to set a a
standard that they don't want to set I
get all that it's the one time the
fighter actually won it's never happened
before ever Francis won in every way
possible so if you are anti- Dana
Francis your guy he's sticking it to the
man my God is he's sticking it with that
big
Big Easy
fist easy we're
live good job case thank you for saving
that
case you haven't been this excited in a
hot second man insane historical it was
more massive even after like I remember
like the buildup wasn't for some reason
wasn't like that crazy but afterwards it
was everywhere literally
everywhere every news article dude I
haven't missed one of my my son's
baseball practices I had to to miss it
for this because at 11:00 I started
grilling at 11:30 we're eating by noon I
figured the fight go on about 1:00 my
son had practice at three I'm like we're
good three rolls around these hoes
aren't even walking out it's Becky G
Dance I'm like oh hell no and my
following I was like I'll take in
practice you stay and watch the fight
I'm like you sure he's like I got this
so he goes I stay and watch the
fight
insane yeah they need to work on the
production part for sure oh it's bad
yeah yeah
but also kudos to those guys Brett
okamoto killed it I loved him on there
that's a Denver kid I love Denver kids
Brett killed it on there those two the
uh what's the name Tori the the host and
then uh Bradley Tim Bradley Timothy
Bradley yeah
him you know little tough little tough
on there I mean they had to Vamp for
like two hours that that that's the
thing I'm giving them all the praise
because if you've ever been in TV and
stuff like that when they're when
they're like hey you got four hours to
fill you're like so Francis used to pick
up dirt in Africa we're like you covered
that he's like I know I we have nothing
to run with here like you know it's so
tough France's favorite food when he
comes to Vegas is you're like what is
happening right now but sh Kudos I'm
shout out to those guys that's a not an
easy gig but BR Brad okamoto killed it
though killed
it the other thing that was aning it's
same thing the NFL's doing NFL right
Taylor Swift get get offer small titties
they're just all up honor the NFL just
keeps just marketing Taylor Swift Taylor
Swift in the crowd Taylor Swift this
Taylor Swift catch by Kelsey Taylor
Swift you're like oh my God shut up with
them they kept going check out the stars
who are here it's Kanye West
Ronaldo who else was there uh Kanye West
Ronaldo Conor McGregor Eminem Eminem
that's right so many times yeah and
Eminem do you have to flip us off every
time you take a picture hey you won dude
you're worth like 500 mil do you have to
be still so salty and mad all the time
we need a middle
finger it's strange they didn't show any
of the celebrities Kanye West is here
the camera definitely do not show him we
do not want him here please don't show
him that's what they were doing Ronald
got booed every time my dad was like why
are they booing I'm like cuz he turned
down the contract to play there that's
why I couldn't hear where I was at but
dude he's so tall I didn't know he was
that tall he's this tallest sty Bender
yeah fre freak yeah freaky
yeah what an experience Francis bton now
though didn't he look like in the later
rounds he looks so tired but he didn't
fight tired but he looked so tired like
he was just breathing out of his mouth
yeah it was insane man insane yeah
insane going to take a little break
insane the the funniest tweet is when I
was when I was is making fun of the
production on Twitter and on Instagram I
post it some guy goes I illegally
streamed and I feel ripped
off internet stays undefeated time
speaking of undefeated man this episode
of the shop Show Breaking Down Tyson
Fury and Francis and ganu the most
historical fight and Combat Sports
history uh I'm doing all this while I'm
rocking my sheath underwear I'm I'm
rocking them right now I haven't taken
them off since they sent me a goodie bag
and they know I like don't send me them
bright colors now come on now you know I
don't like those bright colors you know
I don't like the whites it's too
dangerous down there man I get the dark
ones and sheath underwear makes the most
comfortable breef of all time I
seriously haven't taken them off I'm
obsessed with these undies way better
than anything I've ever promoted I'm
telling you man I'm obsessed with sheath
they're so damn good they're so
comfortable uh sheath is particularly
useful for staying cool if you're
working out or in the hot environment
but also keeps you warm like it's chilly
today all good good baby and I
absolutely love the Dual pouches for my
man pieces down there putting him in a
freaking strangle hold when I need it
sheath uses materials like bamboo and
mesh for even more cooling Comfort they
are by far Barone the most comfortable
underwear the most stylish underwear
they fit great they fit my big ass
perfectly all you got to do is go to
sheath underwear. comom right now use
promo code shab that's SE Au received
20% off today that sheath underwear s h
a t under we.com right now use promo
code shab Au for 20% off the best
underwear you will ever put on your
freaking body all
right one second here
DraftKings we got some Draft Kings oh
NBA is here you got the
freaking you got the World Series
popping right now I listen I start off
the season I'm a I'm big Rangers Fan
Seager one of my favorite players he
used to be a Dodger and then the these
Diamondbacks there's something about
these underdogs man getting it done I
thought they should have won the first
game but again Seager showed up in the
seventh hit that I'm sorry hit that bomb
in the ninth and drugged it into uh
Extra Innings and they got the win then
Arizona Diamondbacks beat the breakes
off of them but either way you can watch
the World Series and basketball is back
as well you have UFC this weekend
there's so many things you can beted on
using freaking DraftKings new customers
can score $200 instantly in bonus bets
for throwing down $5 on the NBA win or
lose it does matter you'll start the
season with an instant dub and with
draftking parlays everyone's got a shot
at even bigger basketball wins string
together multiple bets from the same
game or build your parlay across
multiple games for a shot at making your
payday even sweeter Milwaukee looking
pretty tasty with Dame Dillard right now
and The Greek Freak basetball is more
fun when you're in on the action
download the draftking sports app right
now use code shop show new customers can
get $200 in bonus bets instantly for
betting just $5 only on draft King
sports book with the codee shop show the
crown is yours gambling problem I got to
read all this don't I Jen yeah gambling
problem call Way h00 Gambler visit www.1
1800 gambler. net in New York call 8778
Hope n or text hny 467 369 in
Connecticut help is available for
problem gambling call
8887895118 Kansas leny partner Golden
Nugget Lake Charles Louisiana 21 plus
age varies by jurisdiction void in
Ontario bonus bets expire 168 hours
after issuance see sportsbook.com
draftkings.com
sportsbasketball terms for eligibility
deposit restrictions terms responsible
gaming
resources I think next time me or case
could read the the last part if you want
it's up to you though that'd be nice and
take all my energy I'm rocking my Freddy
Krueger team my Freddy Krueger kicks
still think they're fake
whatever what else you got chin all
right um anyway so since Francis won
this or not won this fight since he did
really really well um apparently the W
the WBC president said he will be ranked
in top 10 in the heavyweight he beat him
that's how you know he beat him and this
to my point you boxer now yeah France is
boxer now so he can make a ton of money
after this Fran boxer now and to piggy
back in what DC said DC knows tough men
DC said Baran Francis lanu is the
baddest man on the planet yep hands down
he ain't lying who's gonna beat
him Jon Jones you here's my thing and I
and I I'm on record saying I thought
John would have smoked Francis after
watching what he did against Z gun
watching Francis vers Wilder or vers
Fury I'm like oh he oh he beat John I
think he beat John MMA MMA whoa who
think he knocks him out I didn't realize
how good he was I knew he was good he's
the heavyweight champion I didn't
realize he was this goddamn talented I
knew he was a freak athletically I
didn't know he was I didn't know he was
world class
boxing beat the greatest of all time
good who
did this is
nuts that's a that's a huge take right
there yeah dude Jon Jones Jon Jones has
been your number one forever too yeah he
is I love John John has one pack right
now yeah that's
true
wow and but there's more to it UFC
messed up John's
out stipe's waiting for Jon those two
are going to retire so that's a
legendary fight I don't think and J said
this as well I don't know if we ever get
that fight now we might but now you got
Tom asol you got Sergey in there now I
think Tom mops the floor with him
but the greatest heavyweight is not in
the UFC ready for this the greatest
heavyweight at boxing and mixed martial
arts is not in the
UFC who's gonna beat
Francis who the hell is pfl GNA get to
fight Fran in MMA the answer is nobody
so again be cool pfl you signed he boxer
now he all boxer he top five boxer in
the world we can't play grab ass and
have him fight some no nameer in pfl
just for get his rocks off we're talking
30 m you can't afford my boy now man you
can't afford Francis we ain't trying to
see him in pfl is it better production
than the that Saudi thing we saw yeah it
is I'm not trying to see that hey you
know what I'll wait five hours watch
Francis box how about themm apples I'll
wait five hours of pure to
watch Francis fight now you won me over
Saudi you drinking a sun kiss yeah zero
sugar hell yeah wish we had Frescas dude
I've never tried a fresco actually oh
you're missing out man what else you got
you mentioned Tom Aspen and Sergey
pavlovich I showed you this on fight on
the kid the odds were in aspo favor in
the beginning like five days ago so he
was a minus 130 and then pavlovich was a
plus 110 but five days later now aspinal
is the underdog crazy crazy now now if
this was a normal fight and asol had 12
weeks he doesn't get touched by Sergey
he mops the floor with him that's how
talented Tom is but on short notice I
still think Tom gets it done Sergey is
gonna blow his wad in that first round
Tom's too smart too high of a fight IQ
uh I think he either I think he submits
him submits him or tkoos him doesn't go
all five it's a a great fight without a
doubt no matter what though I hate that
it's on you know twoe notice that's what
sucks that's what sucks about the last
card like everyone's on such a short not
noticed it sucks it's good for the fans
sucks for the fighters good for the ufd
sucks for the fighters yeah um so this
this is when Israel was there in Saudi
Arabia he's he's saying like I think he
was talking to Mac Mack life and he's
saying uh his return would be 2027 I
don't know if he might be joking but he
said
2027 yeah get you a rest man he deserves
it that's a long rest though huh it's a
very long rest but he's he's done enough
work he he's earned that he's done
enough work where he can take three
years and be relevant and he's so you
know active on social media and he's all
over the place I love that Usman and
Izzy were in francis's corner Francis
you know he said he's gonna start doing
stuff in Africa and once pfl to be part
of it he's goingon to do that I'm sure
Usman I he's gonna help with that 100 Iz
he's always relevant that's the
difference back back in the day say
Chuck Liddell took three years off after
you lost the fight dude there's no
social media you're not on podcast
there's nothing to do Iz he can go on
flagrant he come on my show he can do
whatever he wants and just stay relevant
he's witty he's he's funny he he can
stay relevant he doesn't need to fight
to stay relevant without a doubt that's
the difference between the New Age and
the old heads the old heads take three
years off he might as well just retire
is he take three years off not a big
deal D that's a long time but yeah
that's a very long time but he is a
especially it's a long time to go from
that and then jump right back in at a
very high level because I assume he
jumps right back into the title shot
yeah for for the shame is for uh DDP for
dupes he's like dude he's like out to
dry you know he had his one shot in
thefc he's like n you
wait so if I'm D forget about I he and
just focus on the division he's still a
top four guy top five guy but you're
you're not fighting Izzy anytime
soon yep and it seems like Izzy was more
angry with dupus than than he was with
Izzy so dupes dupes can still go fight
for the title and and the Poli needed to
do his thing not not Izzy's thing yeah
Al so do you remember this clip from a
while ago this Conor McGregor on his
yacht and he said he got tested multiple
times by usada because he did re-enter
the usada testing pole so it did turn
out that he was really tested twice and
gave three samples so that's legit and
he passed yeah I mean so far it doesn't
say like he failed so wow yeah so that
was legit apparently they actually went
on his yacht which is I don't know how
they they got to jump on there drink
some whiskey you got it how else you it
yeah yeah I it's a i Conor has to feel
some type of way because what Francis
pulled off Connor was hoping to do even
though Connor set the the table for
everyone to do all these fights like
this of this magnitude he was the first
you know he's the the first guy to do it
but Conor never had that moment Conor
didn't land you know he land that
uppercut on Floyd but he he got
dismantled you could tell that Floyd was
carrying the fight so they had I'm sure
Conor has to feel some type of way like
damn you know yeah he gave him props
obviously but um how could you not I
know uh but yeah Conor got the real bag
that time though the 100 Mill or
whatever that was so they say so they
say yeah uh your boy that you're super
high on Ian Gary apparently he got
kicked out of his team because rumors
are that Leon Edwards didn't want anyone
to make him look or didn't you know it
it would mess with his like you know
confidence if someone's beating him on
the mats or whatever so apparently he
was kicked out of the team because of
that that's from Ian Gary's perspective
though what dude what a great PR move uh
I had to leave the gym because I was
beating up the World Champ so damn bad
tight move dude yeah they wouldn't allow
me they would allow me to train with the
champ because I was whooping his ass so
I could go find a new team lanna's head
coach had an issue with me training on
the mats have asked me not to train
there Leon doesn't want any insecurities
or doubts of his own mats within the gym
which I don't fully understand I get
that we're both in the top 10 you might
see me as a threat but I'm not a threat
to you right now I'm not fighting for
the title right now his coach said the
words Ian is a threat I cannot not have
Leon having any doubts or insecurities
that makes you think someone is
weak-minded I can't have another
Contender training on the mat that's why
gym conflict is annoying I get how that
goes for me why not have that other
Elite guy on the mat why not train with
him why not have him push you why not
learn grow from each other I'm I'm with
Ian on this has that happened in your
gyms yeah really so a top level guy yeah
what there there'd be a young guy me and
then there's another guy who even if
they're different weight class or same
weight class the young guy starts to go
up in the rankings and starts to take
some of the shine away and the coaches
start to pay attention to him because
they're like oh this kid's the next
thing then the older heads are like hell
no man so creates this weird divide MMA
teams don't know how to deal with
it that's how good Ian Gary is this is a
great thing for Ian I have to leave the
gym because I'm beating the out of
him
okay that's cool oh you don't want to
get better
okay because not kick him out cuz he's
getting beat up up
yeah tell you he Gary's that guy
man yeah you've been big on him for a
while now yep uh so stie remember we
were talking about this how it's weird
you were saying it's super weird how you
know how this is playing out the whole
stti mioi Jon Jones thing interim title
all that stuff so stti actually said on
a I think it was a podcast he was saying
like he was wondering why he wasn't
offered the interim shot even though
Dana White said we wouldn't want to give
him the interim because that's a
disrespectful to Stipe but Ste was like
why didn't I get the shot he's not
getting younger Jon's out for at least a
year so it I don't know they decided to
move on say cool with it for Stipe it's
tough though too man because you're G
wait on John you're Assuming he's coming
back Blown Blown ripped off the bone PEC
is a bad injury man you're just gonna
sit around you haven't fought in a while
anyway you're just gonna sit around and
wait for John it's tough yeah and then
then Aspen is only getting better
Aspen's Gonna Be Active sergey's going
to be active those guys are only getting
better it's tough for these older heads
man definitely um and speaking of let's
see uh speaking of injuries Hamza shov
apparently this is from okamoto you know
he thought he broke his hand against
volcanos oh not Usman uh apparently it
was uh torn ligament that's bad so it's
but it's only like brace for like four
weeks that's not bad it's not so the
recovery time is way better than an
actual can fight for the title yeah if
he he could probably fight for the title
in February February March
yeah definitely they have that Saudi
Arabia card in March Ian it's a it' be a
Fight Night for us but you could do
Strickland versus Hamot there it sucks
for for Strickland he's like what why am
I going to Saudi Arabia
yeah all right we knew sub was up with
Hamot right just didn't look himself
yeah I thought this was really cool so
remember this picture I think we showed
it last week uh so this in makev and
volkanovski together in front of like a
restaurant or something apparently Islam
Mev paid for volkanovski's whole team
for their lunch they found out later on
so this is what Craig Jones that BJJ guy
who trains volovski he said that he said
that that's what they did which is super
cool that's really cool yeah I mean he
also took the fight on 11 days notice
and saved the card it's the least you
your opponent you know no I no I think
he's a really good dude Islam's a great
dude yeah um that Izzy shorts fire that
he has on too yeah St one old school
all right um you know what we should
probably take another quick little break
right at hour happy hippo are you
talking about that happy hippo dude I
just before the show you hear me ranting
I'm on that freaking crom on that
pineapple grapefruit flavored katum this
the powder put it in here your boy get a
rolling it is the best katum on the
planet only crom that I trust crom out
there is the wild west but I ask them to
be part of the program because you can
trust their freaking Crum however you
want to get it powders pills they K dips
they get the energy shots the
concentration katum shots they got it
all the One-Stop shop and you get is it
20 or 30% off 20 right 20 20% off when
you go to happy hippo.com promo code
thick with three C's thick boy all right
is the promo code you get 20% off for
life of the best Crum however you want
to get it I love the powders because it
works quicker for me but they have the
energy shots they have the Taffy they
have gummies they have powders they got
cadps they got it all it's the One-Stop
shop to get your mind right get your
focus it's happy hippo.com prom code
thick
23 nice and uh this is from our own keto
George he said he's they said on the
broadcast during the the fight for ganu
and uh Fury that the Saudi Prince gifted
inano a handmade $4 million sports car I
don't know if this is legit uh uh a
panagi I think it is is it I don't know
oh yeah but that's in that's insane if
that's true here's what's insane I've
sat in those I don't fit okay so so he's
it's gonna look like a micro machine oh
my go bring up a pagi yeah panagi sports
car PA a there you go is that it I'm
scared of just type in car I don't know
what the hell you put
there p a g a n
i PA a go for it again PA
a
p a g n i g oh there it is Pagani right
yep and then go to
images oh damn yeah I've seen these
before these're so expensive nobody can
afford them they're so look that one 6.5
and they usually the whole body's carbon
fiber here's the thing there there's not
a chance I F I've I've tried to S one
before I don't know how Fran do sick oh
they're filthy
dude but they're for like Elon m and
Mark Zuckerberg like the
normal car consumers not 6.5 what excuse
me yeah they look freaking sick though
straight race car dude yeah hard to get
I would imagine 6.5 million but even if
you have the 6.5 they're hard to get oh
that's the just in yeah you can just
walk in and buy it yeah even if you had
the money you still can't buy it you
have to be a part yeah super tough to
get like Bugattis you can get you can
get them used but to get a new one
insane mhm oh so I saw this recently oh
damn I don't know how real this is but
this is uh Yuri prashka and this is from
crunched this is his new haircut do he
get do he put extensions in it has to be
extensions because I went to his his
stylus his dreads in the back that's
usually frowned upon for white
girls she has like a crazy haircut well
everybody in that thing except for the
one guy on the left looks normal damn I
don't I'm feeling that for this fight
man you bet you better win is this the
image you're talking about damn There's
an actual poster legit people sent me
stuff yeah I'll find it it's the it's
them face to face and both have the war
paint on okay we have to find it if
anyone knows please send it to that one
makes me sad it's like Blurry on the
left he's like in his sheath underwear
swinging a sword and on the right you
just I mean it's a it's a
disaster but this is no I'll find it
Terence mcken this all right hopefully
we can find it uh this I thought was
super funny so funny I was going to
Repose it like yeah people think I hate
Dana and I don't in any facet in any
facet so people that are listening it
just says the third judge in sa araba
who scored shows Dana
with yeah like in in costume or whatever
uh yeah also yeah that's his Instagram
page his hair does look longer but those
those are definitely extensions and look
he has like a box squ it's a nightmare
yeah his his facial hair and hairstyle
is like his fighting style it's all over
the place give me one more dude where
I'm pretty sure that's pretty much it
yeah we'll end on y's haircut and style
there it's a
disaster in a in a great way in a great
way speak of great you got freaking one
Championship on Amazon Prime you fight
FS it is going down in four freaking
days this Friday on Amazon Prime you
have freaking UK's London's greatest
Jonathan haery versus Fabricio Andra it
is the bantamweight kickboxing World
Championship then you have the Phenom
Ruto the welterweight submission
grappling World Championship the first
ever vers mamed it is going down Ruto
going to time in some freaking Russian
knots and then you know I'm with my boy
Hagerty man he's one of my faves so make
sure you tune in that's on Amazon Prime
you know nobody does a better one
Championship get you some you also got a
fight night going down Saturday yep I'll
have this on the Green Room as well I
will be in a freaking uh where am I
headed I am headed to Niagara Falls you
you have to bring it up CH okay I'm in
Niagara Falls right outside Buffalo at
senica casino one show Friday one show
Saturday I'll be watching One
Championship on Friday I'll be watching
UFC Fight Night on Saturday in The Green
Room you have alme versus Derrick
Lewis uh you got Dolby versus bonam it's
not a crazy card but yeah H Holo is
fighting vers pusan that's great fight
fun fight I should say great allall
relative Alo derck Lewis is interesting
that's great yes that's a that's it's
just Clash of styles to the
fullest either way man it's all about
Francis Tyson Fury that's all I care
about uh nagar fall see this Friday and
Saturday come on out Buffalo not that
far of a trip for you uh those shows are
damn near sold out one show Friday one
show Saturday the great Brett Forte will
be with me then Chicago the keep on
trucking tour keeps on truck in Chicago
December 8th and 9th two shows Friday
two shows Saturday Nashville January
25th Austin January 26 get your tickets
right now at thick boy.com all right
kids that's it I was excited to do this
one um love you guys as far as the truck
content we are damn near done the first
episode should be coming out soon
converting my TRX from 702 horsepower to
well over a th000 horsepower at the
wheels yeah dude so we got to shoot the
footage before I blow this thing up but
we'll have the first episode out very
soon second episode to follow it's
getting nuts those out there but we'll
release all that you see on my social
media you see it on the new YouTube
channel all the the truck footage and we
have more plans I'm so excited for this
but uh it's all about Francis and Tyson
Fury all right shout out to Francis
shout out to Marquel Martin you guys
freaking did it proud of you guys be
nice to each other have a very happy
Halloween uh see you
guys